[Music]
you shot edge of tomorrow before you
were pregnant I did yeah and you are in
insane shape in this movie we have and I
think is still of you in this movie and
I think you were doing intense amount of
yoga because there's a scene where
you're doing a like a one-armed yoga
your whole body is parallel planked and
you are holding yourself up with one
hand and I just it blew my mind I could
never in a million years do that well I
took a lot of I mean it I couldn't do it
at the beginning I had like trained for
ages to do it oh it's training huh okay
that's what always gets between me and
excellent this violin doesn't sound
right but it's really impressive that
you could do that I mean you must be
free for the longshots we're at to hold
it for a long time they put a little
wire on my ankles like oh wow we needed
a little help for those long shots I
remember when I was holding it we were
doing we were kind of rehearsing the
scene and Tom took a little too long
with his line coming in it was the only
time I snapped at him during the show I
went yeah you gotta come in quicker with
the line cuz I can't hold it I can't
hold it for that long and he was like
sorry you talked to Tom Cruise that way
that's pretty impressive Tommy huh let's
go
[Applause]
and and you you must have been gotten in
such insane shape where it was at a roll
intimidating tear to your husband I mean
was he was right on it all intimidated
by this I think John was scared that one
morning he'd wake up and I was just
benching him up over your head
what is this you learned a self-defense
technique of fighting technique because
the movies fantastic I love the movie
you're so the fight scenes are so
realistic and good and you clearly have
studied real martial arts I did I
studied um Krav Maga which is the
Israeli martial art it's very lethal
right and kind of use every part of your
body to annihilate somebody wow this is
the Israeli so yes okay all right
so I learnt that and um yeah that was
them it's a very aggressive form have
you at all thought to yourself okay if
what if in real life I needed to disable
somebody have you what what's the Krav
Maga move that you would use well it's
weird because when I was shooting the
film I went to see a movie one night and
there was a guy next to me and we all
know it when people are on their phones
during a movie and texting the light is
distracting right yeah so he was texting
and I just gently just said I'm so sorry
would you mind just not doing that while
watching the movie and he got he was he
gave me a look like oh my god he could
clock me and I was thinking my head what
if he just I don't know why so it was
like what would I do if this man and
you've been trained yeah I'm sitting
that planning might make-believe attack
that never happened so what would you do
I'd probably go for the balls right
[Applause]
someone is that what they teach do they
teach there or is that just your
instinct no is that everyone's instinct
just I'm gonna die Oh women just or is
it something you've learned yeah yeah no
they do teach you how to knee someone
repeatedly in the balls yeah but it's
weird I was talking to John about this
this came up but I was saying like is it
just unbelievably painful for a guy when
you get need or punched in the balls or
anything like that and he was like it's
like unbelievable like you can't compare
it to getting punched in the boob it
doesn't compare cuz I was like well
surely it's problem is same I get
punched in the tit or something he was
like not at all the same and then he
said something which I found very
interesting that he said I think it
would be more painful and I want to ask
you this is true more painful sometimes
like a tap on the ball might be as
painful as a punch in the bowl is this
true I'm glad you asked a punch in the
ball is worse okay is much worse wrong
I've been tapped on the balls many times
I find it pleasurable
we thought he was napping very deeply
but he just liked it yeah I'm trying to
wake him up yeah but I've been punched
in the tit and I don't like that at all
there are you coconut man say how can a
man oh yeah how can how can John say no
it's worse than being punched it for a
woman to be punched in the breast cuz he
doesn't know what it's like to have
boobs no unless all right